j'ouvre évidemment notre second thème
tout de suite second débat consacré aux
effets du changement climatique des
catastrophes climatiques les mers sont
en première ligne on l'a encore vu cet
été la sécheresse la canicule et puis
diluvienne et bien sûr ces incendies de
forêt qui ont frappé des régions
jusqu'ici épargnés comme la Bretagne ou
qui ont connu une ampleur historique
comment Gironde c'est là dans les villes
de Landiras et de Biganos que
mathiasarayz a rencontré des élus qui se
disent des armées face au réchauffement
on voit des souches la parcelle
entièrement brûlée et la plupart des pas
en brûlés comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure il y a que les feuillus qui ont
résisté un petit peu mais cela dit ils
sont quand même brûlés à Landiras c'est
près de la moitié de la surface de la
commune 2000 hectares qui sont partis en
fumée cet été un incendie hors-norme qui
reballe les cartes de la lutte contre le
changement climatique dans une région
pourtant habituée au feu de saison ce
réchauffement climatique nous inquiète
quand même parce que je pense que les
étés seront de plus en plus chauds je
pense pas que c'est une c'est un secret
donc cette année on avait des
températures à 42 degrés
malheureusement il n'y a pas de raison
que ça n'a rien ça n'en revienne pas et
le problème c'est que ça revient souvent
avec 90% de départ de feu d'origine
humaine le risque de voir l'histoire se
répéter en 2023 semble inévitable pour
Bruno Laffont maire de Biganos et
président de la défense des forêts
contre les incendies en Aquitaine la
première arme c'est la pédagogie il y a
des jours à risque où il ne faudra pas
aller en forêt et il faut que les
concitoyens comprennent aujourd'hui les
Françaises et les Français que vivre à
côté d'un massif forestier quel qu'il
soit en France quel qu'il soit en France
il y a des comportements et des choses à
faire des choses à ne pas faire face à
la sécheresse ou aux fortes chaleurs les
élus de terrain sont désarmés restent
alors la possibilité d'une gestion
responsable des massifs fait de la
prévention c'est à dire que avec nos
budgets avec ces sommes là que nous
avons récoltées et bien nous nous
faisons des ponts des points d'eau des
pistes forestières et après nous comme
nous connaissons bien le massif et bien
nous sommes en appui avec les pompiers
ce qu'on appelle les conseillers
techniques historiquement fortes la
relation pompier pouvoir public cette
intensifié ces dernières années de
partenariat se traduit par des réunions
fréquentes des rencontres régulières
par la contribution des services
municipaux à un exercice d'un centre de
secours les commissions de sécurité
permettent aux élus locaux de rencontrer
nos effectifs et là aussi également les
services de l'État bref la question de
sécurité civile et partagez tout au long
de l'année entre l'ensemble des
intervenants en Gironde premier
département de France en termes de
départ de feu les parties se réunissent
d'ailleurs déjà au cœur des discussions
la saison des feux qui débute au sortir
de l'hiver
les élus les maires en première ligne
face au catastrophes climatiques
voltallem de ce second débat sciences
public toujours depuis le salon des
Maires de France j'accueilliriques
menaci bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes le
maire de Trèbes co-président du groupe
sur la gestion des risques de l'AMF
Magali regazzi bonsoir bienvenue à vous
vous êtes maître de conférence en
géographie à l'École normale supérieure
et membre du Haut Conseil pour le climat
Laurent delquero bonsoir bienvenue
bonsoir chef du projet stratégie de
résilience des territoires du chiffre
project et Laetitia cruppa éditoris
politique est évidemment resté à mes
côtés résilience voilà un mot dont que
l'on va beaucoup employer dans dans ce
débat la capacité à résister aux chocs à
ceux réinventer après une épreuve Eric
menacile les habitants de votre de votre
ville ils savent de quoi on parle avec
ce mot ils ont vécu il faut le rappeler
deux drames majeurs en moins d'un an en
quelques mois
oui très bien vécu deux drames majeurs
d'abord les attentats au mois de mars
2018 et ensuite les inondations vous
savez vous vous ne sortez pas indem de
ce genre de situation aujourd'hui la
préoccupation majeure lorsqu'on évoque
la résilience c'est de pouvoir se
projeter ce projeter en a cultura les
populations mais surtout en ayant
conscience que le risque fait partie de
notre vie et que la meilleure façon de
l'appréhender c'est de mieux le
connaître et je crois que que l'AMF a
mis en place ce groupe de travail que je
cours préside avec le maire de Mandelieu
mon ami Sébastien Leroy pour justement
essayer de d'aider les élus locaux dans
cette démarche il existe depuis quand ce
groupe de sur la gestion des des risques
est-ce que c'est finalement récent
oui c'est assez récent David Lisnard a
souhaité sensibiliser les maires de
France à cette problématique vous savez
lorsque vous devenez maire d'un village
d'une ville
au-delà de la joie de l'élection je
crois que la majorité de nos collègues
on appréhende pas les risques majeurs
aujourd'hui il ne suffit pas d'habiter
en bord de mer il ne suffit pas
d'arrêter à proximité d'un cours d'eau
pour être potentiellement soumis à un
risque climatique alors on va évidemment
détailler tout ça Magali regazit les
phénomènes météo qu'on a vécu cet été
ils sont amenés à se reproduire est-ce
que c'est une nouvelle norme climatique
qui est en train de de s'imposer
finalement à nos consciences et à celles
des élus évidemment oui en fait ce qu'on
a ce qu'on a vécu cet été finalement
c'est un peu la répétition générale de
ce qui nous attend dans les alors 10 15
prochaines années on a effectivement un
ensemble de risques sécheresse vague de
chaleur inondations on a même des Raichu
encore c'est un vent violent on a vu
aujourd'hui il y a encore des articles
dessus retrait gonflement des argiles
c'est les fissures sur les bâtiments sur
les maisons sur les infrastructures pour
faire vite on a 60% de la population
française qui est déjà exposée à ces
fameuses aléas
hydroclimatiques avec un climat qui
change dans un climat qui a déjà changé
et bien on sait que ces aléas secs
chauds humides ils vont devenir plus
fréquents plus intenses plus précoce et
plus long et ça ça a des conséquences en
chaîne ça évidemment des conséquences
d'abord sur les personnes avec de la
surmortalité ça a des conséquences sur
les biens les infrastructures ça a aussi
des conséquences en chaîne sur
l'agriculture donc aussi sur les
ressources des communes donc ça veut
dire c'est ça qui est passionnant c'est
un nouveau modèle évidemment que qu'on
est un peu obligé de réinventer et on
est à la fois dans l'urgence et dans le
temps long c'est ça qui est compliqué en
réalité aujourd'hui les territoires il
doit faire face à trois impératifs
différents le premier c'est la gestion
des catastrophes naturelles il y en a
toujours eu le climat varie
naturellement simplement là on a une
pression supplémentaire du climat c'est
à peu près 30 à 40% du total de
l'augmentation des sinistres ensuite il
faut aussi réfléchir à ce climat qui
continuera à changer tant que la planète
va se réchauffer et ça ça veut dire
s'adapter à un climat futur de la France
dans les 10 15 20 prochaines années pour
juste cet été on avait une anomalie
thermique de 3,3 degrés cet été va
devenir entre guillemets la norme d'ici
une vingtaine d'années et donc on va
déjà devoir s'adapter à plus de trois
degrés et puis et puis on a aussi besoin
de travailler sur ce qu'on appelle
l'atténuation de ce changement parce que
c'est pas du tout la même chose si on
est à 1,5 degrés ou à 2 degrés et donc
les mers doivent tout faire ils doivent
faire la gestion du quotidien immédiat
l'adaptation de leur territoire mais
dans une nouvelle donne avec des
incertitudes sur l'économie la
démographie les finances publiques et
avec des moyens on en parlait dans notre
première partie qui sont pas forcément à
la hauteur et puis ils doivent aussi
engager cette transition vers le bas
carbone parce que derrière là aussi les
coûts de transition sont forts et on le
voit avec la crise énergétique
évidemment ça pèse là aussi sur les
communes et donc on a deux logiques soit
la logique du cercle vertueux ou tout ça
s'aligne et finalement ça devient une
opportunité pour transformer les
territoires soit au contraire et bien on
s'inscrit dans des logiques de
verrouillage des émissions et de mal
adaptation et là on va condamner des
territoires a finalement courir après
des crises et à un moment donné à se
détériorer en continu alors c'est pour
ça que dans ce débat on va à la fois
tenter d'être sur la réponse d'urgence
et et aussi un peu sur le temps long le
rend delquero cette résilience des
territoires finalement dont vous êtes
chargé au chiffre project je rappelle le
chiffre projet qui a été créé par
Jean-Marc jankovici qui qui propose des
des réflexions en profondeur secteur par
secteur sur les modèles vers lesquels on
doit aller avec des solutions on est
vraiment dans le concret
c'est le passe par quoi pour vous
et bien elle passe la décarbonation
c'est peut-être le premier mot qui qui
vient l'abandon des énergies fossiles
oui alors justement
Magali disait il faut en même temps
s'inscrire dans une décarbonation dans
une sortie des énergies fossiles pour
éviter le pire mais on voit bien et
l'année 2022 est un une bonne
illustration que
on a aussi intérêt à sortir des énergies
fossiles sortir de cette dépendance aux
énergies fossiles pour pour plein de
bonnes raisons parce que aujourd'hui on
cumule en 2022 avoir une sécheresse et
une crise énergétique en même temps
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé
cette année et personne n'a envie de
cumuler les deux donc on a besoin
absolument de sortir de ces énergies
fossiles non pas seulement pour éviter
le pire c'est à dire se réchauffement
global à l'échelle de la planète mais
pour tout simplement la sécurité le
bien-être des citoyens et c'est pour ça
que nous on a repris ce terme de
résilience c'est-à-dire cette capacité à
faire face aux crises aux crises
climatiques à la décar formation à la
transition énergétique et surtout cette
capacité à se transformer parce que ce
qui est important c'est que dans un
monde qui est devenu totalement
instable le climat est instable les
ressources énergétiques vont être de
plus en plus difficiles à mobiliser dans
ce monde là la résilience la capacité à
faire face à être moins vulnérable elle
passe par la transformation Laetitia
dans la présentation que vous faites
madame par exemple de la responsabilité
auquel sont confrontés les communes on a
l'impression qu'elles sont seules or il
y a d'autres strates il y a la région il
y a déjà le département la région et
puis l'état enfin la commune seule le
maire ou la mer n'est pas seul face à
ces risques climatiques et puis ensuite
on se poserait évidemment la question le
maire n'est pas seul mais le maire il
est quand même le premier acteur de la
sécurité de ses administrés et donc
quand il y a une crise le premier qui
est sur place le premier qui doit faire
face ça reste le maire même si derrière
effectivement il y a l'ensemble des
services de l'État qui peuvent
accompagner il y a des niveaux de
gestion mais le maire c'est quand même
celui qui au quotidien il a tous les
inconvénients c'est à dire qu'il doit
gérer l'urgence il doit faire face à
l'urgence sociale à l'urgence économique
il doit faire face à l'urgence des
finances il doit répondre en cas de
crise c'est lui qui vient annoncer les
décès ça je pense qu'il faut quand même
le dire aujourd'hui en France on meurt
déjà du climat qui change quand il faut
adresser un décès dans une commune et je
pense que Monsieur le Maire de trèble
c'est on imagine pas pour avoir fait des
entretiens en tant que chercheur avec
des élus surtout dans les petites
communes on est en direct avec ses
administrés et là il y a un point
d'alerte immédiat c'est que certes on
peut créer tous les instruments on peut
créer toutes les structures on peut on
peut tout faire à un moment donné on a
des élus qui tous les jours tous les
jours sont en contact sont sur le
terrain et ce que je constate et c'est
quelque chose de nouveau ça fait près de
20 ans que je travaille sur les risques
de catastrophe naturelle moi je vois une
démission des élus je vois un moment
donné des gens dans petite commune
ils font pas ça pour la gloire ils font
pas ça pour le pouvoir ils font ça pour
aider le collectif et je vois des gens
qui me disent madame je n'ai plus envie
et c'est pas un problème simplement
d'État c'est pas un problème d'argent il
y a quelque chose qui se passe
aujourd'hui qui fait que notre logiciel
n'est pas forcément le bon face au défi
de la transition qui est aussi comme on
l'a dit au-delà du climat Éric mais là
si on va s'appuyer sur votre expérience
donc c'était il y a 4 ans ces
inondations
4 ans après par exemple on parle de
mauvaises nouvelles il y a quelque chose
de très concret c'est c'est la partie du
territoire de votre commune qui est
devenu un constructible c'est-à-dire il
faut annoncer à des à des propriétaires
à des habitants bah non vous pourrez
plus vivre ici c'est ça c'est ce qui
s'est passé
j'ai envie de vous parler de difficulté
sur deux axes bien différents d'abord je
crois que magalie a raison je crois que
la vraie difficulté elle est d'abord
humaine bien sûr lorsque vous
administrez une commune quelle qu'elle
soit vous gérez des hommes et des femmes
et cette dimension là je crois que elle
doit être au cœur de nos préoccupations
gérer l'humain c'est gérer ce qu'il y a
de plus difficile et gérer l'humain en
période de crise c'est souvent hyper
compliqué notre travail à nous il doit
il doit s'articuler autour de l'humilité
l'humilité par rapport à la gestion et
aussi l'humanité l'humanité devant des
crises énormes et devant des souffrances
qu'on ne peut pas décrire ou qu'on ne
peut pas imaginer moi je voudrais
revenir sur le climat
vous savez le climat aujourd'hui on nous
annonce depuis des décennies qu'il est
en train de changer nous voyons au
quotidien qu'il est bouleversé et nous
constatons surtout dans l'arc
Méditerranée mais pas que et plus
particulièrement dans le département de
l'Aude la vulnérabilité de notre
territoire des incendies des inondations
et je crois que la première des qualités
de mer aujourd'hui c'est à la fois de
pas se tromper de combat nous ne sommes
digne des experts ni des spécialistes
encore moins des ingénieurs nous devons
donner un cap politique en nous appuyant
bien sûr sur des expertises mais nous
devons apporter cette sécurité dans
l'ambition politique et ensuite l'humain
l'humilité pardon dont je vous parlais
elle est indispensable elle est
indispensable parce que aujourd'hui non
seulement le climat change mais
l'aménagement urbain va changer alors
justement je repose la question sur les
zones inconstructibles qu'est-ce qui a
changé après les les inondations
peut-être que je me suis trompé mais
j'avais cru comprendre qu'il y avait une
partie du territoire de la commune qui
dans le destin avait changé quoi
radicalement aujourd'hui 52 maisons ont
été détruites sur sur la commune de
Trèbes je sais pas si vous imaginez le
désarroi que peut constituer la
démolition d'une maison parce que bien
évidemment nous avons été accompagnés
financièrement par le fond Barnier et
fort heureusement d'ailleurs donc le
fond Barnier c'est quand justement quand
il faut reloger
se substitue par le biais d'un mécanisme
assurantiel qui se substitue aux
communes et qui permet de faire
l'acquisition de maison mais au-delà de
cette dimension financière qui est
indispensable lorsque vous perdez votre
habitation
toutes les dizaines de milliers d'euros
qui puissent qui peuvent arriver ne
peuvent pas compenser la dimension
personnelle liée à votre bien et ça je
crois que les maires comme l'a dit
Magali nous sommes avec nos équipes
municipales en front office par rapport
à tout ça il y a des cellules de crise
enfin j'essaie d'imaginer je vous vois
bien bien sûr en direct avec vos
montrer mais il y a des cellules des
crises qui existent vous êtes aidé par
des associations enfin j'imagine
j'espère
vous savez la cellule de crise elle est
bien là bien sûr elle est là quelques
jours après la catastrophe elle est là
peut-être quelques semaines après mais
tout ceci se gère dans le temps long
vous pouvez pas imaginer la gestion de
ce type de crise à la petite semaine ça
se joue sur des années sur des décennies
et et l'enjeu pour notre République
c'est de faire en sorte que justement
nous puissions mettre en parallèle cette
résilience humaine sur la résilience
urbaine alors justement et l'objet de ce
débat c'est aussi de proposer peut-être
à ceux qui nous qui nous regardent des
clés des solutions Magalie
je reviens vers regga zit pardon je
reviens vers vous parce que il y a
peut-être un bon conseil à donner quel
conseil de
une sorte je sais pas quel long terme
d'audit en vulnérabilité c'est à dire
qu'il faut que les élus se disent ok
est-ce que moi je suis vulnérable ou pas
face à ces aléas climatiques lorsqu'on
constate d'abord c'est que malgré la
l'arsenal juridique qui existe en France
toutes les communes ne sont pas égales
tous les diagnostics ne sont pas fait et
c'est vrai quand on dit un élu on va
faire un diagnostic de vulnérabilité
c'est pas très attractif pour le
territoire en plus à faire l'autruche
quoi
un diagnostic par rapport à quoi par
rapport à l'existant par rapport au
climat qui change par contre ce qui est
intéressant quand on fait le diagnostic
c'est aussi d'avoir les ressources et là
aussi on va avoir besoin d'identifier de
nouvelles ressources le sol on en a
parlé l'eau la forêt c'est à dire que là
aussi les compétences les compétences
sur un territoire les compétences
métiers le vivier ce qu'on a des jeunes
est-ce qu'on a des vieux est-ce qu'on a
des familles est-ce qu'on a chaque
territoire va être différent si vous
voulez pour faire simple c'est un peu
comme un médecin le diagnostic qui peut
être posé facilement on a la science on
a tout ce qu'il faut on a assez d'accord
les traitements existent et ils ont été
à peu près évalués on sait voilà sauf
que quand vous arrivez chez le médecin
bon on va vous dire alors vous vous êtes
plutôt jeune et en bonne santé on va
plutôt vous faire ce traitement là ça
aura plutôt tel effet positif plutôt tel
effet négatif mais à la fin vous allez
vous en sortir comme ça et puis sur
telle autre territoire on va dire ah bah
peut-être donc c'est une autre personne
elle est plus âgée là par contre ça va
pas marcher y compris dans certains cas
on va devoir accompagner la
relocalisation la reconversion mais là
aussi on a besoin de changer de discours
la transition c'est ce que font les
maires au quotidien c'est à dire un
territoire qui change dans un projet de
territoire et aujourd'hui en fait ce
dont on a besoin c'est de se dire plutôt
que de dire c'est un problème d'écologie
c'est un problème d'énergie non c'est le
problème d'une évolution territoriale
qui prend qui tire les leçons de ce qui
s'est passé qui accompagnent aussi les
transformations pas à pas et qui par des
ressources parce qu'il y en a énormément
dans les territoires alors est-ce que ça
suppose je vais vous donner la parole
tout de suite est-ce que ça suppose de
mieux former les élus à ses enjeux de
catastrophes climatiques ou plus
généralement donc tu as d'urgence ou
temps long la transformation
environnementale c'est ce que propose
finalement le gouvernement le ministre
de la transition écologique il était ce
matin sur RTL et puis il l'a confirmé
ici même au salon des mers et des
collectivités locales ils ouvrent une
sorte de guichet préfecture par
préfecture pour former les maires de
France on écoute Christophe Béchu c'est
très simple l'idée c'est dans les
préfectures dans les sous-préfectures
donc près de l'endroit où chaque mer
exerce ça fonctionne d'avoir un temps de
formation de sensibilisation qui va être
organisée par les services par les
agences de mon ministère Météo France
l'ADEME l'Office français de la
biodiversité non pas pour seulement
regarder la situation à l'échelle du
monde mais pour regarder territoire par
territoire ce que sont déjà les
conséquences du dérèglement climatique
et la manière dont on peut prendre des
mesures pour l'atténuer et pour faire en
sorte de s'y adapter le rend delquero il
y a des milliers de mer qu'on peut
attendu le gouvernement pour se former
aux enjeux climatiques mais quand même
est-ce que c'est c'est une étape
importante oui et pour nous il est
vraiment important que que les maires
soient mieux formés il y a la question
de la compréhension de ces enjeux
climatiques et je répète
on peut pas distinguer des enjeux
climatiques des enjeux énergétiques et
ce serait une erreur de les séparer donc
et je veux bien revenir aussi sur votre
question pourquoi les territoires
pourquoi c'est si important les communes
on l'a dit c'est l'espace évidemment de
des spécificités en termes de
vulnérabilité qu'il faut identifier en
termes de ressources pour bâtir des
bonnes solutions mais c'est aussi
l'espace de la proximité avec les
citoyens et là il y a un rôle important
du maire il faut déjà que le maire il
comprenne bien ces questions là ces
questions elles sont complexes parce que
les événements climatiques sont
interdépendants les uns des autres et
ils demandent d'ailleurs à être bien
conseillé pour prendre la bonne décision
parce que ils ont besoin de bien
comprendre pour prendre la bonne
décision et puis ils ont besoin de bien
comprendre aussi pour faire la pédagogie
du problème auprès des citoyens et ça
c'est un c'est un rôle je crois très
important de par la proximité de par la
confiance malgré tout que les citoyens
ont avec leurs élus de proximité il y a
vraiment un rôle important les gens les
citoyens sont un peu perdus aujourd'hui
à ce que leurs élus leur mère leur
explique un petit peu sans être un
expert mais leur explique un peu que
c'est si ces crises là elles ont elles
sont amenées à se reproduire qu'elles
soient climatiques qu'elles soient
énergétiques et qui est donc il faut s'y
préparer et donc et je crois que c'est
c'est vraiment un enjeu très important
qui passe comme ça vient d'être dit par
déjà une formation meilleure une
compréhension meilleure par les élus de
ces enjeux là et un partage avec
l'ensemble des du territoire aussi de
cette compréhension
peuvent être formés tous les maires bah
là c'est ce que propose le gouvernement
puisque ce sera ce sera dans les
sous-préfectures et les préfectures on
verra et aujourd'hui vous pouvez pas
quand un maire prend ses fonctions on
lui explique le Beaba de la gestion
communale voilà sans forcément en faire
un expert en comptabilité publique et
bien c'est la même chose aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui être maire avoir des
responsabilités sur un territoire et
bien ça nécessite d'avoir le baba des
enjeux climatiques et des enjeux
énergétiques ça tombe bien un maire on
en a sur ce plateau Eric mais là si
est-ce que vous vous ressentez le besoin
d'une formation sur ces enjeux
climatiques où est-ce que vous vous
dites bah non j'en sais assez
ce que nous ressentons à l'AMF c'est ce
besoin peut-être pas de former mais
d'informer nos collègues mère
aujourd'hui comme le disait monsieur je
pense que la majorité des maires ne
mesure pas en fonction du territoire
dans lequel ils vivent la dangerosité
d'un bouleversement climatique et la MF
s'est saisi de ce sujet alors le
gouvernement l'a fait aussi je crois
qu'il faut le faire peut-être que nous
ne sommes pas assez de deux à faire ça
mais en tout cas l'AMF a pour but encore
une fois pas de former les mères mais de
les informer mais je reviens à la
question ce diagnostic de vulnérabilité
parce que c'est important ça va te
plaire il y a le diagnostic de
vulnérabilité et ensuite peut-être la
réponse la formation elle dépend aussi
de du degré de vulnérabilité oui ou non
oui oui mais je vais vous donner un
exemple que je connais le mieux celui de
mon territoire les inondations de 2018
ont généré auprès de la population
aujourd'hui une peur quasiment
irrationnelle
en clair dès que les périodes automnales
arrivent notre population du moins une
grande partie de la population se trouve
dans une peur panique d'éventuelles
puits à venir et comme vous le disiez
monsieur a juste titre notre rôle c'est
non seulement d'aculturer les
populations mais aussi de diffuser une
information sur la potentialité du
risque c'est ça qui est important Magali
regazza Zazie je voyais ticket quand je
disais la formation est pas forcément là
la même en fonction du niveau de
vulnérabilité il faut que tout le monde
faut est-ce qu'il faut qu'on parle tous
le même langage sur ces enjeux
finalement ça fait des années qu'on
tourne autour de ça on l'a déjà fait sur
les risques enfin voilà maintenant c'est
le climat mais peu importe il y a deux
choses différentes il y a effectivement
la claque et je parle vraiment de
claques quand on intervient en tant que
scientifique devant des élus en général
ils se prennent effectivement une baffe
et moi la première qui ne travaillait
pas au départ sur le climat la première
les premières fois où j'ai vraiment
rencontré des scientifiques du climat
c'est vertigineux
on se rend compte qu'est-ce que c'est
climat qu'est-ce que c'est l'énergie
qu'est-ce que c'est que la crise de la
biodiversité et donc on voit c'est ce
qu'on appelle la sensibilisation après
il y a la formation par rapport aux
instruments législatifs juridiques par
rapport à l'expertise par rapport à la
gestion communale d'une certaine façon
c'est pas que dans les risques comme
vous l'avez dit ça dépend de tout là
aussi il faut distinguer les communions
parlent beaucoup des mers aujourd'hui on
a des communes de quelques dizaines
d'habitants on a des coeurs de métropole
on a des communes rurales des communes
urbaines des communes périurbaines on
parle très peu des Outre-mer mais les
outre-mer en soi c'est déjà tout un
sujet les territoires insulaires en
réalité derrière qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'avec la meilleure
formation du monde à un moment quand
vous êtes dans la cellule de crise quand
vous devez annoncer gérer être en lien
avec le préfet on a besoin effectivement
d'en accompagnement des élus dans le cas
où les collectivités territoriales ne
l'ont pas on a aujourd'hui un mille
administratif avec les interco les
communes les régions les départements on
pourrait dire et ça fait des décennies
on oppose l'État et les locales on est
pas on oppose les régions et les interco
où se dire on a un super bongrenage
faisons fonctionner ce qui existe dans
certains cas l'interco va permettre
justement parce qu'elle a des moyens de
rassembler les élus j'étais vendredi
dernier au Havre j'ai eu la chance de
participer à la fabrique de ce qu'on
appelle un pcaet un Plan climat énergie
territorial j'ai vu des élus d'une
compétence rarissime franchement il y a
beaucoup de gens qui devraient aller
écouter ces élus leur parler du
territoire la fabrique même de ce pcaet
c'était l'occasion de parler et de
monter en compétences autrement dit on
apprend aussi en marchant on a besoin
d'élus et là j'insiste et c'est quelque
chose qui a été dit par vous deux
le diagnostic c'est celui des experts
ensuite arrive les politiques qui
prennent les choix y compris les choix
de l'inaction la responsabilité
politique c'est un moment de dire j'ai
choisi ça en connaissance de cause
j'assume les conséquences aujourd'hui
nos élus ils doivent faire face à des
décennies d'aménagement du territoire
qui ont ignoré les risques Monsieur le
Maire de Trèbes ces maisons qui ont été
détruites c'est des héritages souvent de
ce qui a été fait par le passé lui il
est pour rien aujourd'hui on a la
possibilité de choisir la trajectoire en
intégrant effectivement dans cette
résilience les ressources les choix
politiques et je le répète on a aussi la
possibilité de dire je n'agis pas il
faut juste en saisir les conséquences et
ça c'est du ressort politique c'est
clairement pas du ressort des
scientifiques ce n'est pas du ressort
des experts est-ce que Laurent delquerou
on oppose parce que ce que j'entends
dans vos prises de parole c'est Laetitia
poser la question la question des
strates des différents degrés de
finalement de pouvoir de financement de
prise de décision
là on a un peu le sentiment d'opposer
les uns aux autres et finalement d'un
manque de stratégie qui emmène est-ce
que c'est ce qui manque aujourd'hui on
parle de planification par exemple il y
avait un grand mot dans la campagne
électorale d'Emmanuel Macron c'est la
première la planification écologique bon
pour l'instant l'attend encore un petit
peu
oui enfin c'était de la responsabilité
de la première ministre c'était ça la
grande nouveauté
qui va qui va critiquer la planification
énergétique et on adore ça moi la
question c'est pour que ce soit efficace
c'est indispensable quoi d'une certaine
façon oui et pour que ce soit efficace
je reviens il faut quand même comprendre
un minimum les interdépendances à partir
du moment où vous êtes conscient de
l'Inter de toutes les interdépendants
qui qui qui caractérise ces questions
climatiques ces questions de énergétique
et bien vous voyez bien que seul la
solidarité et la coopération peut être
peut être une réponse adaptée on ne peut
pas être résilié en tout seul si je
reprends ce terme de résilience la
résilience implique même les liens de
solidarité et de coopération plus vous
serez coopératif et en lien avec vos
voisins avec les ceux dont vous dépendez
et plus vous serez résilient donc c'est
si aujourd'hui on observe encore des des
querelles des tensions de la compétition
entre les territoires car elle existe
ça peut aussi être lié à cette non
compréhension de à quel point nos sorts
sont liés et à quel point c'est
seulement ensemble et et encore
opération que l'on sera que son on
pourra faire face à ces à ces enjeux
alors puisqu'on parle de catastrophe
climatique il y a évidemment
un exemple récent qui nous revient
forcément en mémoire ce sont les
inondations dans la vallée de la Roya
notamment on est à l'automne 2020 je
vous propose un extrait de reportage on
est six mois après la catastrophe on est
dans la ville de Breil sur Roy et un
pont de secours et est ouvert par le
maire qui s'appelle Sébastien ola on
écoute
un quartier dans lequel il y a 25
familles donc c'est la mairie qui a
conventionné avec le Centre national des
ponts de secours pour obtenir ce pont et
le département
nous aide à la fois financièrement et en
termes de logistique
c'est une étape extrêmement importante
et symbolique c'est aussi d'une certaine
manière la première pierre de la
reconstruction de la commune de
Breil-sur-Roya alors là on a aussi un
exemple qui est lié à l'urgence à quel
point vous êtes vous en tant qu'élu
dépendant du préfet du département de la
région de l'État finalement pour sortir
votre commune d'une crise climatique
pour adoucir la situation de vos des
habitants de la commune face à cette
situation
écoutez on est interdépendant les uns
des autres c'est une évidence absolue
l'organisation de notre République et
administrative au travers des régions
des intercos du département bien sûr et
de l'état je crois qu'il faut distinguer
deux choses d'abord la gestion de la
crise cette gestion ou Magali a raison
le maire est seul avec ses équipes
au premier au premier rang de de la
gestion de crise et ensuite la
reconstruction ensuite l'aménagement du
terr moi je voudrais que mais pardon je
vous interroge on parlait Magali parler
de de strat administratif est-ce que
quand il y a la crise on l'a vu par
exemple au début de la crise covid
est-ce que finalement tous ces toutes
ces strates là tous ces freins ils
disparaissent pas parce que c'est la
crise il faut prendre des décisions
rapidement et puis réapparaissent après
vous faites appel à l'état par
définition c'est souvent comme ça que ça
se passe quand même par définition quand
vous êtes en crise vous vous gérez comme
vous pouvez
parce que par définition une crise et
quelque chose qui est imprévisible donc
vous pouvez vous préparer
incontestablement mais lorsque la crise
arrive vous devez être organisée
l'organisation vous permet de d'éviter
de perdre du temps et vous permet de
mieux gérer l'imprévisible ensuite par
rapport à l'État mais évidemment
lorsqu'une crise survient que ce soit
les pompiers que ce soit les liens que
nous avons avec le préfet avec l'État
tout entier je crois que on est par
définition très râleur les mères mais on
a un besoin une viscérale de l'État
l'état l'État est dans la mise en action
de nos politiques publiques
indispensables je crois que lorsqu'un
maire est en colère c'est parce qu'il
veut un peu plus d'Etat et alors il y a
une vraie dualité c'est-à-dire on veut
un peu plus de liberté mais on veut un
état facilitateur un peu plus d'État
mais pas forcément des solutions qui
arrivent de justement de de Paris et qui
sont pas adaptés je reprends ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure ils sont pas
adaptés à une solution
locale ça a été très bien dit
aujourd'hui l'intelligence des
territoires je crois que ça ne doit pas
être un vin mot aujourd'hui les élus
locaux ont cette capacité à pouvoir
grâce à des experts grâce à des
ingénieurs à aménager le territoire il
faut que l'État Vienne faciliter la mise
en oeuvre de ces politiques publiques et
ne soit pas une complexité
supplémentaire pour nous c'est tout
alors je voudrais prendre un exemple de
de ces aléas ou de ses catastrophes
climatiques on va parler de de canicule
maintenant et je vous propose un exemple
que ça nous emmène dans la ville de
Strasbourg qui a mis en place des îlots
de fraîcheur donc ça fait baisser la
température sur place dans ces îlots de
fraîcheur de 8 degrés en moyenne
explication de l'adjointe au maire qui
est en charge de la ville résiliente et
son titre elle s'appelle Suzanne Broly
installation qui offre non seulement de
l'ombre mais aussi de la avec des
brumisateurs qui vont rafraîchir la
population l'objectif c'est que la
population puisse trouver des lieux de
refuge en période de canicule et on voit
bien que ça devient le lieu privilégié
de passage ou d'arrêt des gens qui
fréquentent cet espace ce que vous voyez
derrière moi c'est c'est rien c'est un
sparadrap le plus important c'est d'être
des transformations en profondeur ça
signifie qu'il faut des cours d'école
perméables il faut déminéraliser
l'espace public et derrière le replanter
avec des arbres et aussi éviter d'aller
abattre des arbres notamment les arbres
centenaires où il faudra attendre 100
ans avant qu'il puisse rendre les mêmes
services
Magali regga Zazie je retiens c'est dans
les propos de l'adjointe au maire cette
de transformation en profondeur dans ce
cas vous vous avancez l’idée des co
bénéfices donc là on est vraiment dans
la prise de décision d'un élu et c'est
conséquences ça veut dire quoi les co
bénéfices ça veut dire alors c'est pas
moi d'ailleurs qui le dit c'est le
rapport du GIEC donc c'est c'est
l'évaluation de la littérature
scientifique je vous donne un exemple
très simple quand vous arrêtez d'avoir
des voitures thermiques bah il y a plus
de pollution il y a plus de bruit donc
d'emblée vous avez une amélioration
directe de la santé on sait que les
coûts de la pollution aujourd'hui c'est
des morts ça veut dire aussi que vous
allez pouvoir retoucher l'espace public
donc il va revenir peut-être d'autres
personnes quand vous végétalisez vous
allez créer de la qualité de vie quand
vous allez travailler sur l'énergie vous
allez créer des choses qui sont
positives pour le portefeuille vous
allez améliorer le logement vous allez
améliorer aussi les conditions de vie de
nos personnes âgées dans le logement ça
veut dire pouvoir les garder plus
longtemps à domicile ça veut dire aussi
à construire par exemple des transports
collectifs qui permettent alors le
transport collectif c'est pas forcément
du métro ou c'est pas forcément du bus
ça peut être du taxi à la demande donc
en fait derrière on va avoir un ensemble
de bénéfices en termes de santé en
termes d'égalité en termes d'inclusion
en termes d'éducation et ce qu'on voyait
comme quelque chose de pénible de
punitif mais en fait c'est juste de
prendre comme alors ça c'est la base des
crises la crise devient une opportunité
pour faire mieux pour intégrer des
innovations pour aussi se dire bah ça
j'ai essayé par exemple mon arbre je
l'ai planté avec le climat qui change
c'était pas le bon arbre et donc ça
marche pas j'ai décidé de faire des
fontaines quand on a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement ou non la fontaine
c'est pas forcément la bonne idée ça
veut dire aussi que derrière et c'est
très important ce qui a été dit un des
instruments c'est l'aménagement du
territoire et ça c'est incroyable parce
que ça reprend tous les échelons au
niveau national un état stratège un état
qui va redéployer les grandes
infrastructures le rail l'eau
l'industrie l'agriculture au niveau
régional une répartition là aussi par
les enjeux de mobilité par exemple tout
l'action le ferai pour redimensionner et
puis ensuite au niveau des
agglomérations on fait pas la même chose
dans le centre en périphérie mais on se
parle et par exemple l'agriculture dans
les communes du rurales ça peut être
réserve de carbone dans les sols réserve
d'eau dans les sols biodiversité
alimentation locale qui dit alimentation
locale dit petit commerce en
centre-ville ça permet de baisser les
mobilités donc de pas faire que des
voitures électriques on peut aussi parce
qu'on va pas pouvoir non plus tout faire
en électrique et donc en fait on voit ce
que disait le chiffre c'est à dire qu'on
a vraiment derrière une sorte de jeu de
marabout de ficelle où on enchaîne les
choses et où ça devient subitement un
cercle vertueux qui amène du bien-être
parce que ce qu'on sait par contre c'est
deux choses il existe suffisamment
d'argent pour financer cette transition
1 et 2 cette transition elle peut se
faire y compris avec la sobriété dans le
respect du bien-être de tous et de son
amélioration c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est la littérature scientifique allez
je vais terminer il nous reste un peu
moins de 5 minutes un peu plus de 5
minutes dans ce dans ce débat mais ça
passe vite c'est plutôt bon bon signe on
va faire un focus sur la question des
éoliennes et des droits de veto on est
au salon des mers évidemment c'est c'est
vraiment dans les dans les dans les
enjeux et les discussions parlementaires
en ce moment faut-il donner aux mairer
un droit de veto sur les éoliennes la
question vous savez elle est en suspens
dans la navette entre le Sénat et
l'Assemblée nationale quand un calmé
Jonathan du priez sont allés rencontrer
élus et ministres en leur faisant cette
question
alors depuis ce matin on a eu plutôt
l'impression d'un consensus chez les
maires qu'on a rencontré sur le fait que
il faisait face à une crise climatique
et qu'il devait prendre leur part dans
les forêts écouter une réaction il faut
aussi nous donner les moyens de moins
consommer c'est-à-dire de mettre en
place des mesures qui permettent
d'isoler
de développer le transport collectif ça
c'est un des premiers volets le deuxième
sur la question de l'éolien moi je pense
que c'est moi qui suis d'un département
rural l'Ardèche ou on a on a une
ressource en banque et importante mais
on doit pas être la base éolienne de de
tout un pays quoi c'est pas possible
parce que parce que c'est aussi des
paysages qu'il faut savoir préserver ce
qui fait bien sûr des basses et
l'implantation sur le territoire de la
commune de nouvelles éoliennes et à
propos d'un possible droit de veto des
mers certains sont sceptiques écoutés
par exemple ce maire moi les droits de
veto méfie beaucoup ce sont je pense des
des pouvoirs assez excessif je pense
qu'il y a aujourd'hui tout un régime
d'autorisation d'enquête publique qui
font que chacun a la possibilité de
s'exprimer comme je disais on est en
pleine mutation donc il va falloir
s'habituer aussi à ce que les énergies
renouvelables prennent une plus grande
place alors il y a un ministre une
ministre qui porte ce dossier des
énergies renouvelables au Parlement
c'est Agnès panier renacher on a pu la
rencontrer ce matin et elle est
persuadée de réussir à faire à
l'Assemblée nationale ce qu'elle a fait
au Sénat c'est à dire consensus autour
de son texte je ne vois pas comment on
peut voter contre un projet de loi qui
répond à notre défi climatique nous
devons atteindre la neutralité carbone
d'ici 2050 et pour le moment pour
fabriquer des énergies bas carbone dans
les 15 ans qui viennent c'est les
énergies renouvelables le nucléaire ne
pourra prendre le relais que dans 15 ans
un projet qui va dans le sens de la
compétitivité de nos entreprises du
pouvoir des français puisque ce sont des
énergies qui sont beaucoup moins chères
que le prix de l'énergie que nous avons
aujourd'hui sur les marchés mondiaux et
un projet qui est également au service
des territoires voilà les maires qui
demandent à ce que l'effort soit partagé
mais qui sont plutôt favorables ici à se
développements des énergies
renouvelables en tout cas c'est le
sentiment qu'on a eu nous depuis les
années du salon
et on va terminer sur un mot le mot
d'acceptabilité Laurent delquerrous est
évidemment très important on vous nous
avez dit le l'essentiel dans toutes les
réflexions qu'on peut mener avec les
maires peuvent mener face au changement
climatique et aux catastrophes
climatiques c'est commencer par la
question des énergies fossiles donc si
on oublie les énergies fossiles on les
remplace par un mix nucléaire par
exemple et énergies renouvelable mais la
question de l'acceptabilité par les élus
et les citoyens elle est majeure comment
rendre ces énergies renouvelables
désirables j'emploie ce mot à dessin
alors d'abord on va pas remplacer les
énergies fossiles par des énergies
renouvelables on va commencer par avoir
moins besoin d'énergie donc c'est la
sobriété donc le premier point après on
va effectivement avoir besoin de
remplacer les énergies fossiles
résiduelles dont on enfin en tout cas
l'énergie dont on a besoin par des
énergies décarbonées et sur la question
des énergies renouvelables je crois je
reviens à l'idée de la proximité avec
les citoyens qui est quand même ce qui
caractérise le plus les
îlots on fera pas les énergies
renouvelables à la hauteur de ce que
l'on veut contre les citoyens donc
est-ce que les les élus locaux peuvent
jouer ce rôle de facilitation de
dialogue avec les citoyens faire en
sorte que les projets d'énergie
renouvelables éolien ou autre soit des
projets qui associent les citoyens dont
les citoyens voient le retour sur leur
territoire mais on avait pardon en
première partie un élu qui disait moi
j'ai le sentiment d'être un casque bleu
souvent avec dans ma ville des gens qui
s'opposent sur des sur des questions et
alors lui le disait pas mais je sais que
existe dans d'autres villes souvent on a
des points de vue qui sont radicalement
opposés notamment sur cette question des
des éoliennes et c'est le maire il est
entre les deux quoi le maire il est
temps entre les deux d'où la question de
est-ce que le maire est capable de faire
de la pédagogie
de ces sujets-là pourquoi est-ce que sur
son territoire au niveau national on a
besoin
de produire des énergies renouvelables
est-ce que le territoire peut et la
population peut être d'une manière ou
d'une autre associée à ce à ce projet ça
va être non seulement une contribution à
l'objectif national de décarbonation
mais ça doit être également un une
ressource locale et un bénéfice pour le
territoire et ça renvoie aux qualités
que le maire doit avoir encore une fois
les qualités de facilitation de de mise
en dialogue et pas de Paf uniquement de
décision ou d'arbitrage en amont très
très court peut-être qu'une grande
campagne nationale d'informations sur
l'efficacité justement
de l'énergie éolienne de l'implantation
des éoliennes pourrait être utile à ses
maires avant qu'ils aillent au combat et
qu'ils mettent leurs casques bleus
est-ce que vous allez je vous donne le
dernier mot évidemment Eric menacci sur
cette question des éoliennes vous avez
le sentiment de devoir aller au combat
tiens justement je sais pas si on a sur
votre le territoire de votre commune ou
juste à côté non non moi j'ai envie de
vous dire que que la gestion des crises
c'est la gestion des opportunités
transformer une crise en opportunité et
je crois aujourd'hui en prenant
l'exemple des inondations pendant de
nombreuses années
nos concitoyens même les élus étaient
convaincus que l’endiguement de nos
cours d'eau était une règle absolue on
sait aujourd'hui qu'il faut que nous
apprenions à vivre avec nos rivières et
que vous répondez pas du tout à ma
question sur les éoliennes mais c'est
pas grave
les cours d'eau les cours d'eau chez
nous
représentent à la fois un vrai danger
pour nos populations et une opportunité
par rapport aux éoliennes il y en a pas
sur mon territoire bon est-ce que les
maires doivent être des juges de paix
pour approuver nous ne pas prouver je ne
sais pas en tout cas est-ce qu'ils
doivent être dans la chaîne de décision
oui et ben on est d'accord merci
beaucoup et merci de vous être adapté à
cette fin d'émission c'était passionnant
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
numéro de sens public depuis le salon
des mers et des collectivités locales je
vous retrouve demain dans notre studio
au Sénat pour un nouveau sens public et
puis le prochain rendez-vous politique
sur notre antenne Oriane Mancini dans
bonjour chez vous reçoit le maire de
Montpellier Michael de la fosse belle
soirée à toutes et à tous